there's a number of interesting articles
that have surfaced in the last 44 48
hours or so
asking sort of the same question I've
been asking which is whether this entire
sprint of insanity from the Trump
administration is not so much about the
specifics of executive orders and
firings and policies themselves but a
sort of test or introduction to some
broader goal and I suggested generally
on Mondays show the idea that the theme
is consolidation of power for personal
gain for Donald Trump through initially
extreme proposals to be stepped back
from slightly in the future
combined with the disinformation
campaign not meant necessarily to get
people to believe the specifics of what
Trump or Sean Spicer or Kellyanne Conway
or Mike Pence say but rather to get
people to really question whether they
can believe anything that they hear and
create this sort of disconnect between
the truth as it objectively exists and
the public understanding or point of
view on an issue and several articles
have emerged discussing this one has
been very much shared online it's called
trial balloon for a coup by yonathan
dzungar another is called the
information ban is a head-fake and we're
falling for it by Jake Fuentes they
approached this as do I in slightly
different ways but there are some trends
here that at this point are very hard to
deny and that's that this entire first
couple weeks of the Trump administration
is a test to the limits of how the
administration is going to be able to
sort of skirt the law and other
government agencies while setting up the
real policies that they want so let's
look at this list of the real Trump game
here okay step one is you create some
shock events so this includes the
executive orders the banning of
immigrants and people with green cards
then a judge says oh well people with
green cards can come in and people start
paying less attention but Trump ends up
with ninety percent of what he initially
proposed or ordered and it's a shock
event in every sense it wasn't cleared
with too many people in the Trump
administration before being announced
immigrations and customs authorities
were not properly
prepared you use the shock event to then
back off of slightly and still pass 90%
of what you wanted with people paying
far less attention the second layer is
you get opposition growing you get media
coverage civil rights organizations like
the ACLU filing lawsuits lawyers and
protesters all over airports no one
knows exactly what's legal what is and
it exposes to the Trump administration
who is really loyal and who isn't this
includes for example reports of border
agents defying stays from courts on the
Trump travel ban according to both
congressmen and lawyers and choosing to
detain people anyway this is really
valuable information for the Trump
administration which is which agencies
will follow and support him even in
violation of what the judicial system
says if you're attempting a soft coup or
a sort of authoritarian takeover when
agencies ignore courts that is very
useful for you to know and by the way
the fear is always owed the left could
become tyrannical and take your guns or
whatever it's hard to get more
tyrannical than law enforcement ignoring
the orders of judges and courts can you
trust the Department of Homeland
Security can you trust the Attorney
General's Office this is really valuable
information for Trump that comes from
the opposition and media coverage then
number three during the chaos that's
going on because of the shock events
you've caused you continue to make moves
that will have less attention paid to
them for example putting all right
propaganda Steven Bannon on the National
Security Council as a standing member we
covered it it got some coverage on
corporate media but it's hard to keep
the pressure on it since the chaos is
non-stop from the immigration order
another example of making moves during
the chaos the State Department's senior
leadership is fired originally it was
reported that they all quit at the State
Department now it appears they were told
to it eliminates continuity it enables
Trump's inner circle to further
consolidate power by handling the
transition at the State Department
themselves rather with the outgoing
staff and then number four here and this
is really happening frequently you
placate radical groups this is
potentially a really important aspect
the immigration ban which is Trump will
may well lose the green part green card
part of the band permanently but by
doing this he continues to coalesce the
most radical and extreme elements of his
base with the Muslim ban the Muslim
immigration ban the entire not
mentioning Jews on the Holocaust
Remembrance statement which we now know
was deliberate whether you think it was
good bad or whatever it's a sort of wink
and nod to the white supremacists if you
look at the online discussion forums
they see that as a direct wink and nod
to them ask yourself this question in an
authoritarian escalation or soft coup
attempt who's most likely to let Trump
do whatever he wants it's the same
people who are going to be appeased by
things like the immigration ban and not
mentioning Jews on Holocaust Remembrance
Day when Trump was asked just two and a
half months ago if he supports marriage
equality he answered it's irrelevant
because it's already settled
that's a wink and nod to the homophobes
okay and then wrapping up the real Trump
game the big picture is continuing to
consolidate power you get banning on the
National Security Council you take the
Joint Chiefs of Staff and Director of
National Intelligence you only have them
in on an as-needed basis you add power
for chief of staff Reince Priebus also
now on the National Security Council
with the permanent seat we've talked
about Trump's national or I'm sorry
private security force etc you shrink
the inner circle of power and then
lastly here number six watch the money
Trump made a very interesting move by
officially filing for his reelection
campaign for 2020 on the day of the
inauguration it's odd but it allows him
more latitude with fundraising Trump has
already raised millions for his
re-election campaign and this actually
hampers the ability of nonprofits to
criticize Trump as easily because once
he's officially a candidate for an
election criticizing Trump if you're a
non-profit could violate the rules which
prevent nonprofits from participating in
political speech this is the big picture
game here Pat and that's what we need to
be paying attention to it's tough to say
whether this is something that was
intended or if there's this long
I'm out process here sure but every
everything that I can think of that
would make this me feel like he was just
kind of fumbling around in the dark
things like not knowing the policy when
it comes to green cards not letting
people in an administration know to some
extent the people that drafted this were
on the House Judiciary Committee as
staffers not the congressman themselves
indeed that all kind of plays into the
first thing on that list which is shock
events and it makes it irrelevant
whether Trump is a puppet of people like
Steve ban and whoever whoever he's a
puppet of it doesn't even know what's
going on or whether it's calculated the
effect of it is the same we need to be
aware that this is going on we're going
to cover the individual events but we've
got to keep our eyes on the big picture
which is an authoritarian consolidation
of power which could be misused in
disastrous ways I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman send me your thoughts also
tomorrow is sadly I'll talk about this
more on the bonus show today sadly
tomorrow is my birthday and I hate my
birthday at this point starting when I
was 25 I started liking my birthday less
and less and now I really dislike it but
people have asked people have been
asking on the Internet
Oh trust me folks people are asking
whether I'll be doing another birthday
membership special and I will be doing
that just sign up for our newsletter at
david pakman.com to be notified tomorrow
today's show is made possible in part by
blue apron fresh high-quality
ingredients actually make a difference
when you're cooking so it's important to
know where your food comes from and with
blue apron you know exactly where it
comes from and for under 10 bucks per
person you get easy-to-follow recipes
with you know I love this by now the
pre-portioned ingredients so that you're
not throwing out leftover ingredients
it's everything you need to create
sustainable delicious home-cooked meals
in 40 minutes or less some upcoming
meals I'm waiting on my blue apron
delivery it's happening on Monday some
of the meals available in February
include cashew chicken stir-fry with
Tango mandarins and jasmine rice ooh da
noodle soup with miso and soft-boiled
eggs and crispy barramundi with quinoa
and roasted carrot salad you can check
out this week's menu get your first
three
meals for free of course with free
shipping at blue apron dot-com / Pakman
that's blue apron dot-com / PA que ma n
if you try out some of this month's
recipes let me know what you think of
them I will be cooking up some of them
next week